LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
I'm Louis Gray from GDL, and I
have with me two distinguished
guests, Colt McAnlis
and Ilya Grigorik.
Thank you for coming,
gentlemen.
COLT MCANLIS: Thanks
for having us.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Thanks.
LOUIS GRAY: And we're
here to talk about
web performance today.
And if you remember from the
keynote, it seems like so long
ago now, but it was only about
five to six hours, we were
talking about performance and
speed and simplicity and all
those things that really are
part of Chrome and really part
of everything that Google
is doing with our
approach to the web.
And so I'm really happy to have
Colt and Ilya on here.
Both of them have spoken a lot
about making the web faster
and Chrome tools that will
get the job done to make
everything go more quickly
for the web platform.
So I want to just get
really started.
Web performance is really all
of what we do at I/O and
through the rest of the year.
You guys even have
a booth upstairs.
I just checked it out,
which is great.
Why so much attention on
web performance, Colt?
COLT MCANLIS: Well, as every
app developer knows, as we
start to bridge into mobile,
it's not just about network
performance anymore, about
how fast your page loads.
It's about how fast the page is
to respond to the user once
they're in it.
So we have to feel like apps,
which means developers have to
worry about the three pillars
of performance now--
network, rendering,
and compute.
And because of this, we've got
a lot of presence here, a lot
of great talks going on to try
to help developers start
talking about this, bring this
mental model to the table, and
show them what tools they
need to get things done.
LOUIS GRAY: It's interesting
you bring up networking,
rendering, and computing.
I came from a world where
computation was always the
bottleneck.
And it was the server
that was slow.
And I think what you've seen
with networking is networking
has grown exponentially,
10X each round.
And it's really become something
where the data
center kind of becomes a cloud,
and you don't think
about the server anymore.
And it's the network that's
the bottleneck.
And that, as you mentioned,
can be really
difficult and complex.
So what are you guys doing up at
the booth to take all that
complexity and make it simple?
COLT MCANLIS: Well, we
absolutely are sure that it's
super-complex.
I mean, we, as the Chrome
developers, spend a long time
architecting this stuff.
What we've actually done is
we've assembled all of the
brains at Google who deal
with performance on
a day-to-day basis.
And we basically have them
standing around for about
eight hours answering
questions.
In addition to that, they're
going to be walking you
through the tools that we use
for internal analysis and all
of our profiling and showing
you how to use them.
And at best, if you bring us
one of your sites, we'll
actually tell you what's
wrong and how to fix
it as soon as possible.
LOUIS GRAY: And so that's the
performance Ilya shared.
COLT MCANLIS: Absolutely.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, I like the
idea of hearing a bunch of
gurus standing around,
like, at my service.
What exactly are they
going to be doing?
Is it like I show up with my
laptop and they're going to
tweak my browser settings,
or what's the deal?
ILYA GRIGORIK: We won't tweak
your browser settings
necessarily, although maybe we
could, because as you saw in
the keynote, we have the Chrome
data compression.
That's already a nice one
that you can enable.
But as a web developer, I think
another thing that we
can take away from the keynote
is not only is the web getting
faster, it's also getting more
ambitious in terms of the
applications that we're
building, which is why we care
about rendering performance
like 60FPS in a browser.
For game developers, this has
been a day-to-day thing.
For a lot of web developers,
this is a new concept.
So upstairs we're talking people
through the steps of
what are the tools in Chrome
that can help you figure out
what are the rendering
bottlenecks?
Maybe you have a CPU bottleneck,
a compute
bottleneck, or maybe
it's networking.
So, for example, for networking
we have a suite of
tools called Page Speed, which
is basically like a
performance linter.
You run analyze, and it tells
you here are the 10 things you
should fix right now.
And then we can also provide
some tools to help you
automate that web performance
best practice, which is great.
LOUIS GRAY: Isn't it true you
never really eliminate the
bottleneck.
You just move it to
a different place?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Absolutely.
That's what happens.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's the way
we always learned that.
I mean, if you get out of this
spot, you're going to find
something else that's hot.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
LOUIS GRAY: So you're talking
about really like a
performance analysis service,
finding the best stuff, and
finding how you can
optimize for that.
I know we often have
you online at GDL.
I appreciate you coming
on and talking about
making the web fast.
What are those things that web
developers can really key on
to try and make their pages
load more quickly?
What are the things that really
are the slowdowns?
I think one of the pieces that
was touched on in the keynote
was the option to get away
from possibly JPEG
and moving to WebP.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
LOUIS GRAY: Can you talk
a little bit about that
compression and things
that are out there?
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's a
really cool example.
So it turns out for an average
page on the web today, over
60% of all of the data
transferred is actually images.
So we're building pages which
are very media-heavy, lots and
lots of images.
And with WebP, we can actually
give or provide about 30%
better compression over JPEG.
And what we didn't mention in
the keynote was an 80% win
over PNGs, which we often used
for alpha channel and
transparencies, which
are very popular in
games and other places.
So you put those two things
together by using something
like a WebP format and you get
a huge savings, which fewer
bytes transferred, which makes
the page load faster.
It also decreases the
cost of your page.
I think it's something that we
forget on our 4G connections.
For a lot of users, bytes are
expensive, so reducing that
amount is actually very,
very beneficial.
LOUIS GRAY: You mentioned
4G connections.
I'm going to date myself a
little bit and go back to
talking about modems.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Sure.
LOUIS GRAY: So the web, they
just announced its 20th
anniversary essentially.
And so some of us have been
using the web for a long time.
And some of us were using
Mosaic and Netscape
Communicator and all those cool
things, where you had
essentially gray pages with
blue links, and when you
clicked through, you would
get to text files.
And you had to do that, because
the downloading speed
wasn't even possible
to load an image.
And it was painful to download
hundreds of kilobytes of data,
which are things we absolutely
take for granted.
And I think often what we run
into is if you have a pipe and
you make that pipe bigger, the
people who are designing your
apps are going to
fill that pipe.
And so how do you manage that
kind of one-upmanship on the
equipment side that's really
sucking down the data to the
people that are creating bigger
and more greater apps?
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think it's
a challenge to both us
developers on Chrome
and Google and
all the rest to make--
so we want to build more
ambitious applications.
We want life streaming
to happen.
We want to deliver rich media,
rich games in the browser and
all the rest.
So developers keep pushing us
to build more ambitious
applications, which means
we need to improve the
performance of the web, the
performance of the browser.
But it is a collaboration.
We can't fix everything within
Chrome, which is why we have
the performance area, where
developers can come, show us
their application, and it gives
us feedback as a browser
developer to say, here are the
things that we need to
address, help developers fix,
or vice versa, like we were
not educating developers
about something.
LOUIS GRAY: What is it about
Chrome specifically that makes
you say it's speedier?
What is it that we
can test on?
And what's different
about that browser?
COLT MCANLIS: Well, from the
ground up, we always focus on
performance.
I mean, that's one of the
cornerstones of Chrome that
started in the beginning was we
need to make a faster, more
secure browser for people,
because that enhances the web
experience for everyone.
The browsers get better,
the web gets better,
everyone gets happier.
So we do a lot of things across
network, compute, and
render to make sure
this happens.
V8 is by far one of the top
JavaScript VMs out there.
The way we handle rendering and
our utilization of the GPU
is top tier.
We do things that no
other browsers can
do just right now.
Networking, we do a lot of great
stuff, like the Flywheel
technology, as well as the way
we're compressing the network
transfer stuff.
ILYA GRIGORIK: A really cool
example with network is Chrome
literally learns the topology
of the web.
And it becomes faster
the more you use it.
We learn your browsing
patterns.
And next time you open the
Google News homepage, we say,
hey, we can preload these other
pages to make it seem
faster, pre-rendering and other
tricks under the hood.
LOUIS GRAY: So a lot of
precaching and fetching of
pages that I might go to in the
future, almost like cheating.
I think one thing that Linus,
I believe it was, touched on
today, they looked at the
performance of Chrome on
JavaScript, both on desktop
and on mobile.
And on the desktop side, year
over year, maybe we
increased by 50%.
And I apologize if I get
the number wrong.
And in mobile, it practically
doubled.
And so when you look at mobile,
how important is
making the web fast relative
to desktop?
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, it's
everything right now.
As we've already talked about,
the amount of content coming
from mobile platforms is
eclipsing desktop.
More and more and more
we're seeing that.
And especially it's becoming
the life force for a lot of
these small businesses that rely
on mobile for their input
and their income.
A user visiting a website
has a different sort of
expectation when they
visit it on mobile
than they do on desktop.
And so decreasing the load
time, increasing the
performance is going to be
critical for these guys to
stay afloat as the technology
moves forward.
LOUIS GRAY: Well, I know we
actually did this pretty fast.
It's good for guys
who are doing
performance to talk quick.
And I appreciate your
performance on it.
I appreciate you joining
us at GDL at I/O.
For those of you who are on the
live stream, we're going
to get back to your
sessions next.
And follow us again.
We'll be GDL at I/O again at
5:20 talking about Drive.
See you there.